Einstein spent working as a physicist in
Berlin between 1914 and 1932 this talk
from Odyssey bookstore in South Hadley
Massachusetts is an hour several things
that I'd like to talk about for you
tonight and they're centered on the book
of course but also on why I chose to
wrote it write it and why I chose to
write it in the way I did because in
fact I was trying to do something that's
controversial at least amongst those who
wonder about how you can actually find
out something about a time that is not
your own the question then animated this
book from the beginning for me was
questioned I wondered about since I was
actually a teenager which is why did the
20th century fall into the abyss you
know it was truly in many ways a
horrible century even though of course
we can point to all the things that made
it the best of times as well in you know
the advance of human knowledge events of
human well-being all these things were
great in the 20th century but it was
certainly the one in which the most
human beings died by violence in the
history of the species and they did so
in all kinds of strange ways I mean
they're these paroxysm 's of insanity
that that began really with the first
world war which was this huge in some
senses motiveless catastrophe and
continued through all the conflicts you
can think of up until the 1990s with
with disasters like the Rwandan one now
clearly I can't tie everything bad that
happened in the world last hundred years
to the eighteen years Albert Einstein
spent in Berlin but as I grew older and
learned more about the particular
subjects that came to consume my
attention it became clear that Berlin
was a focus of attention because that
was where in fact the modern world order
turned on the question of what would
happen in Berlin who would rule Berlin
what would Berlin itself command all
these were questions that were settled
over two world wars that many people
have said were just one long conflict
and they began almost you know not quite
to the day within three or four months
of Einstein showing up in Berlin not
saying that he was the causal agent
quite the reverse
but the coincidence is there so I wanted
to understand what went wrong in Berlin
both as a source of many of the troubles
that followed and also as a case study
for what goes wrong when when human
social order goes recklessly dangerously
off the tracks
but why Albert Einstein yeah there's a
perfectly understandable sort of macro
historical reason for looking at Berlin
there also lots of it's you know more
local more particular reasons but why
Albert Einstein I mean great man though
he was unquestionably and I spent
fifteen years of my life working on his
his life and work for different media
but what was it about Einstein that
makes him the focus of this and there
are several reasons one of which is the
one that was alluded to in the
introduction which is that he was very
clearly an actor in the drama that was
going on in Berlin between 1914 when
things seemed okay to 1932 when things
absolutely we're not and also if this is
in some sense as I have seen it a drama
in which you have reason on one side and
reckless just sort of unseated passion
and the hunger for power and the rewards
that illegitimate Authority gives you on
the other hand combines with all kinds
of other pathologies and the the anger
that comes with the loss of an
established life all these things that
weren't simply madness were certainly
part of the thing in Berlin that was all
on one side and Albert Einstein was the
symbol of and voice of not merely the
the sort of impersonal symbol of a very
different view of how human beings
should live in the world and he actually
tried to make a difference in Berlin and
he was in fact the greatest scientist of
the 20th century who pursued that
extraordinary accomplishment of human
reason in the middle of a
war torn city whose politics and whose
company he mostly disdained so I thought
putting them together and trying to see
how they work together would be useful
and of course they threw themselves
together and that's where the story
itself begins the meta historical
question that I'll raise now briefly and
I'll raise at the end briefly is can you
in fact make sense of a time and place
not your own by looking through the eyes
of a single person can you do even this
rather muted form of great man history
great man history has been subject of
much disrepute for a couple of centuries
I would argue very much that you can and
that Einstein's experience in Berlin and
my experience of trying to understand
Berlin through Einstein shows that you
can but as I go through the next 20
minutes or so of talk trying to persuade
you of that you'll have to decide if I
have done so all right how did Berlin
and Einstein come together it's actually
a notable question because Einstein
up to the moment he was lured to Berlin
seduced to Berlin had not shown any
affection for Germany quite the reverse
he had been born in Germany he'd been
German citizen up until the time he was
15 when he left Germany and abandoned
his German citizenship with no other
national papers available to him at that
time he accepted the role of a stateless
person as this you know quite young
teenager rather than persist in a
culture which he already at that time
saw as unacceptable
there's more practical reason also if
he'd stayed in Germany he'd stayed in
Munich in secondary school for another
year to past his 16th birthday he would
have been subjected to conscription into
the German army I have to say you know I
and a number of other people written on
Einstein and tried to wonder what it
would've been like for the poor drill
sergeant who had to teach Einstein had a
March and step but that was that was
never put to the test one side note on
that as well it's interesting that
Einstein at this age was not a pacifist
he did not object to all armies when he
did eventually become a Swiss 'iz and
Swiss citizen he was liable for
induction into the Swiss Army and he
actually went along for his physical and
was rejected because he had flat feet
but he went along he accepted that as
part of the price of Swiss citizenship
so it wasn't that at this age this time
was life he objected as he later did
passionately to the whole idea of
bearing arms and placing herself in the
position where somebody else could tell
you to shoot someone did he he later
found that a completely repulsive
concept but not then it was just that he
wasn't prepared to be a German soldier
and he left Germany in Switzerland where
he where he did move after after several
months in Italy with his parents he
found what he regarded as what he called
Layden's like that oasis of civilization
in switzerland was the country he loved
the best Zurich where he went to
university was the city he loved the
best in Switzerland um it was a you know
a perfectly congenial place to him he
had troubles with his university time he
had a great time with his last year of
secondary school in a small town near
zero but he had trouble with authority
even Swiss Authority and and had some
problems in the last two years of his
university education but he still loved
Switzerland he the trouble in university
manifested itself practically as a loss
of any any ability to get a job in the
academy after after he had graduated
unlike all the others who graduated with
him but two years later with some help
from a friend he got a job with a Swiss
Patent Office from 1902 to 1908 he
stayed at the Swiss Patent Office and
the reason I sort of emphasize 1908 is
that what many people regard as
Einsteins greatest period of scientific
creativity many people not me was 1905
when he invented the quantum theory of
light the with his explanation of the
photoelectric effect he solved some
fundamental problems in statistical
physics that led to new ways of figuring
out the sizes of molecules and atoms and
of course he invented special relativity
for which he did not win the Nobel Prize
by the way and he did this while he was
at the Patent Office and even with all
this and the acclaim that actually very
quickly followed he stayed at the Patent
Office because among other things the
salary was better at the Patent Office
than it was as a junior faculty member
in Swiss universities any lux resulting
he he did once he did enter the Academy
went first he had a minor appointment at
the University of Bern and then he had a
pointment at the University of Tara and
then he got a better offer from Prague
full professorship and more money and so
forth so he to his wife's distress left
is there a for Prague worked there for a
little over a year and then got the job
the dream job professorship at the his
alma mater the ETH the the Swiss
Polytechnic in Zurich he was the he had
the chair of physics that the previous
holder had kept him he felt from getting
an academic job so he triumphed over his
enemy and all this it was a wonderful
job yet good colleagues the most
important collaborators he had with the
development of his next great theory
general relativity he had enough money
he had a nice house he had friends he
had people to play music with he was set
and he hated Germany still he regarded
Germany as as just an uncivilized
uncouth place and yet it was into this
perfectly set and happy circumstance
that two of the truly great men of
European science came in 1913 and senior
to Einstein more well-known in the world
at large more powerful in sort of
worldly power but they came to Einstein
and they essentially prostrating himself
at his feet and the image I used to
start the book as this was the visit of
the major and Max Planck and Ernst both
to be Nobel laureates both enormously
powerful men Germany said please come to
Berlin and they made it hard for
Einstein to turn down you know
ultimately Einsteins reasons for going
to Berlin can be understood very simply
he got the best job offer any European
academic had ever gotten he's given a
professorship at the University he was
given the head of his own physics
Institute it was gonna be built for him
he was given the highest salary that
could be paid under German law to a
civil servant professor he was given
Reax s two research funds and best of
all he had zero teaching
responsibilities so any of you who are
in the Academy right now me might
understand what the lure was and unknown
to plunk and Ernst he also had his
mistress in Berlin which was another
year so Einstein hesitated in the face
of this offer a bit but very quickly
accepted and he went to Berlin I mean
essentially he
felt and I think his subsequent
experience proved it that he could do
his work anywhere he needed a pencil
paper and the ability to work
undisturbed and he could do his work and
Berlin offered him the final inducement
which was the finest collection of
scientific talent particularly physical
talent physics talent that was available
anywhere in the world so he had a reason
to go to Berlin even though he was in
his dream job up to then in the dream
city and he just took it but the
question I asked re academic
buccaneering is something that did not
begin with Einstein and certainly hasn't
ended with him but why did Berlin want
this you know in some senses you know
false German so badly that they were
willing to make him an offer that none
of their greats know they're established
and already you know awarded Nobel
laureates there to be Nobel laureates as
fabulous as to have been a German
science why were they giving Albert
Einstein this you know erstwhile German
who had rejected Germany this Jew coming
into a circumstance where Jews were
still suspect this you know wandering
man of uncertain politics and dubious
loyalty to any state why would Berlin of
all places say come to me come and the
answer is I think that the Berlin of
almost every moment up until August 1st
1914 the start of the First World War
was a city desperate to prove itself at
the forefront of European civilisation
Albert Einstein was the ornament they
thought that would help them prove that
to the rest of the world so the point
here long-winded introduction as to why
this juxtaposition I think begins to
make sense is that Albert Einstein to
Berlin in 1913 when this offer was made
and in 1914 in the spring when he
arrived was seen as something that was a
wholly positive thing for Germany so
much so that the value of his present
presence overwhelmed the well-known
negatives of his Judaism and his
complete disdain for mainstream German
politics so in other words Germany in
1914 valued the emblem of reason very
highly and wanted to be seen
the center of European scientific
civilization the apex of where real
thinking the future of humankind was
being developed should be in Berlin
they wanted to diss the perfidious
British they had disdained for the
easily defeated French but Paris and
London were grand cities and Berlin was
an upstart they needed help
Einstein was help so they had our so
essentially the reason Einstein came to
Berlin and Berlin came to Einstein was
to strike a bargain
Einstein would get perfect working
conditions and no trouble Berlin would
get a trophy
Einstein even captured this in an early
letter after the offer was made was it
Punk endurance it came they looked at me
as if I were a prize hen or a rare
postage stamp and then he added I'm not
sure I have any more legs eggs too late
for them she was wrong on that
unfortunately Einstein already being
seen by official Berlin as the patron
saint of reason was to find that being
anybody's patron saint was a difficult
role always and could turn into a very
dangerous role to assume the problems
with the bargain not a love match was
never a love match between Einstein and
Berlin the problems with that bargain
began to become apparent within a very
short period of time obviously here I
mean he arrived in April
August first the war starts and Einstein
has his first real confrontation with
the place he actually went to rot in the
place he thought it was going to and it
was the events of the fall of 1914 in
his circle that I think shaped his
politics his view of Berlin and
certainly shaped Berlin as well what
happened was almost from the moment the
first shot sounded virtually all I mean
to to within one or two individuals
first day all of the German Academy
rallied enormous Lee enthusiastically
around the cause of war and it wasn't
just the well-known right-wing Yahoo's
who populated Germany's social science
and Humanities faculties and those
people had been selected
or their scholarship in support of the
new German statehood for a generation
and they were well you know and it was a
very very right-wing nationalist group
of scholars some brilliant ones but they
were extremely loyal to the idea of the
German Reich what was extraordinary to
Einstein was the way his scientific
colleagues agreed and he became aware of
this really almost from the moment of
the war
Max Planck was the rector of one of the
local universities he sent his students
off to war saying you know we we raised
our german e has drawn its sword against
the breeding gown of breeding ground of
perfidy this was of course Belgium which
had been invaded
without pretext by the German sources of
German forces at the time nernst the
other one of these two mage I ran could
drive a motor car which was still
relatively unusual in 1914 and owned his
own motorcar that was what was unusual
and he drove off into France chasing the
German army to try and serve as a
dispatch carrier something he was so
anything you know this this 40-something
plump of a speckled bespectacled chemist
thought that this was how he would serve
Germany
Einstein's closest friend Fritz Haber
was more practical he used his
extraordinary chemical knowledge also a
future Nobel laureate to explore the
possibilities and military possibilities
of chlorine gas with all the sorrows
that follow up to the headlines of today
these are the people Einstein thought
were his friends his closest colleagues
and even worse
all these men attach their names to the
so called manifesto of 93 which said
Germany is the source of civilization we
are waging our war against those who
would destroy civilization and those who
have the treachery to ally themselves
with with these mongrel races and blacks
Negroes that the British and French
imperial armies were themselves
inherently disgraceful and that was why
Germany was acting correctly in
prosecuting this war
Einstein was shocked by this just found
it horrifying tried to get a counter
manifesto going it was incredibly a mile
just that after the war it would be nice
if scholars from all nations were able
to talk to each other again it's really
just of the counter manifesto he got
four signatures himself the person who
started
the friend of his who actually started
the petition an elderly academic who was
apparently the one man who sort of just
felt this was terrible and another
fellow who had signed the manifesto of
93 and apparently had had second
thoughts and find this one as well and
maybe too signed everything it was put
in front of him for signatures they
didn't even bother publishing the
manifesto he disappeared
Einstein's political life begins here
with this confrontation between the
Berlin he thought he had come to in the
Berlin he actually did come to he did
spend at least some efforts during the
war trying to oppose the war it's worth
noting that his public his sense of
himself publicly as a Jew begins around
this time as well one of his early
published statements on the war in 1915
included the line that the only thing he
could say about war was you should
emulate your master Jesus crisis Jesus
Christ
not Jesus crisis Jesus Christ in words
not in words or song but in deeds so he
was very publicly pushing the mainstream
Germans nose in the fact not only that
he wasn't Christian himself but that
they weren't in his opinion very good
Christians either and that was a very
bold statement in a imperial capital in
the middle of a devastating war and you
know that was of a piece of einstein's
activity through nineteen fourteen
eighteen so two critical things opposed
the war
I mean disgusted by the behavior of his
colleagues he hate him he knew the mass
was not gonna behave correctly he said
so in letters and and conversations
other people but the fact that his
colleagues these men of Reason didn't
was it was just a terrible blow to him
and so when he returned to again and
again in his correspondence and for the
first time this overt Judaism what's
interesting though even though he felt
himself essentially completely alone
completely alienated said he was alone
in an asylum said that Berlin was a
comfortable bed if you didn't mind the
bedbugs all these kind of phrases appear
in his correspondence what's remarkable
at about Albert Einstein you know just
taking aside the confrontation with
building for a moment but who this man
is and why he has the reputation and
fame and why he got the the hortatory
rhetorical power he ultimately did
the period from the fall of 1915 through
the early winter of 1917 February 7 1917
was the other enormous ly productive
period of his life when he transformed
our view of the universe in ways that we
are still in fact confronting and do not
fully understand it was in this period
that he completed the general theory of
relativity which is a theory of gravity
it says that gravity is a function not
of two objects tugging on each other but
the impact of mass and energy on the
shape the geometry of the space and time
in which these objects are embedded it
was a not just a new scientific idea it
was a whole new paradigm paradigmatic
way of conceiving what some of what had
appeared to be long-established in
fundamental physical concepts had to be
he just changed that he transformed it
and in fact the geometrical theme in
physics remains one of its dominant
Damansara modes of inquiry right now I'm
just reading an interesting book by
Janna Levin called how the universe got
its spots and half the book is just
saying Einsteins sort of pre-staged all
of this for us even as we try and do it
now and she's correct I think he did
fundamental new work on quantum theory
he was the first one you know Einstein
later of course posed quantum theory for
all kinds of reasons but people forget
how fundamental he was to its creation
up to the moment that the new
formulation of quantum mechanics was
actually achieved by others but in this
period he first recognizes that chance
randomness some essentially statistical
quality has to be part of quantum
physics the quantum realm of the very
small he didn't like it he wrote letter
saying he doesn't want to give up on
traditional cause-and-effect altogether
but he said the theory is pointing that
direction
this was 1916 and 17 you know ten years
before the famous Solveig conference of
1927 when he decisively broke with the
new quantum theory come and he invented
the whole science of cosmology applying
general relativity to the universe as a
whole as an object of study which is of
course now one of the dominant modes of
doing physics and astronomy that exists
out there all this in about 14 months he
only stopped because he was felled by a
devastating stomach ailment
in 1917 it was an extraordinary period
and as a period that set the stage for
the reason that Einstein remains this
useful focus on Germany through the 20s
because he does this work continues
opposing the war his colleagues continue
to think him not quite a traitor but
certainly irrelevant to politics just go
on and do your work Albert Germany
persists in believing that it can win
the war up until really July 18th of
1918 most of the top people in Germany
and certainly all the people who relied
on their information from the newspapers
believe Germany was at least holding its
own and if not and probably more winning
there were reasons they should think
that but in fact Germany was being
stretched thinner and thinner and from
July forward the triumph of the Allies
was inevitable they overwhelmed the
German army and defeat came very rapidly
and by buying over the summer into the
fall and it came as a surprise I mean it
really devastated Germany so much so
that that was the foundation for the
stab-in-the-back legend that Germany
didn't wasn't actually defeated it was
stabbed in the back by somebody the
Jewish prophet tears at home the home
front socialist politicians you name it
whoever it was and these were
overlapping groups in the minds of the
right but the notion of stab in the back
was promulgated within a very few weeks
of the Armistice of November 11th 1918
and Germany was in chaos I mean whether
or not people believed in the stout of
the back they certainly saw the reality
of a defeated starved broke Germany in
which inflation was already starting to
rise up and there were millions upon
millions of unemployed being added to
everyday by returning soldiers a
generation of young men were dead those
that weren't dead many of them were
terribly injured in the the whole
country was it was just in in terrible
shambles and out of this people were
trying to create something new and some
things were really quite remarkable the
mother of a close friend of mine who
actually a Jewish woman who survived to
Germany during the Second World War
said her mother once told her it was
remarkable she went to bed one night
a subject of the German Empire she got
up the next morning a citizen of the
German Republic and that transformation
was so hopeful for so many people it's
extraordinary I mean freedom didn't ring
and in that context Einstein was a hero
Einstein had been an early voice against
the war he was leftist in his politics
he was completely unemployed in the
madness and Germany and Einstein was
taken up as as a recognized hero and
then was transformed from hero to Saint
by what happened when the British
confirmed general relativity in the
dramatic Eclipse exhibition 1919 all of
a sudden Jensen wasn't just a brilliant
if opaque of scientists he was as his
friend and biographer put it Abraham
Hayes put it Moses from the mountain and
climbed down with new tablets
proclaiming that amidst all this chaos
and horror there is truth and even
though you know as the newspaper
headline said only 12 people can
understand it and is that the other
thing this was taken as an enormous
comfort the sense that you know human
reason had a chance even in the worst
days so Einstein from that point on was
taken up in Germany and around the world
as a symbol of some kind of progressive
hope again why is Einstein useful in
trying to understand history Einstein as
said in the introduction was the first
pop star of science he was from the
moment of the Eclipse expedition
transformed into a absolutely
recognizable worldwide celebrity we
think of the old man with the funny hair
and the the benign gaze but in fact his
middle-aged sort of dramatic look at a
sexy look and he still unkempt hair but
you know some steel black as well as the
gray and all this this great look was
photographed and you know filming for
the newsreels so much so that Einstein
was once asked by some the one person
left he didn't recognize him what he did
for a living he said I'm a
photographer's model and it's
interesting you can actually look at him
as a social as a phenomenon in social
history he was he came along with the
right mystique at the right time when
the technology existed the first time
the technology existed to make and
disseminate there's endless copies of
his image in some ways he benefited from
the fact that the film world had
begun but was still the silent era cuz
you could show him doing his thing
walking around talking and so forth
you didn't have to pay attention to the
fact that if you weren't a German
speaker he was incomprehensible to you
he was supposed to be in comprehensible
it was Albert Einstein and he'd figured
out the shape of the universe but it was
remarkable the transformation in his
life happened within a month to six
weeks to the point where if he said
something in a newspaper in Rotterdam it
would be republished in New York within
a week which got him into trouble when
he's told the Rotterdam paper that he
thought that Americans were colossal
eboard and that the men were the lapdogs
of the women and this was reprinted in
u.s. neo to backtrack and apologize but
no one had ever before confronted in the
sciences confronted this celebrity
machinery and even outside of the
sciences the only real comparable
figures in that time were people like
Charlie Chaplin or some of the other you
know Mary Pickford is the other one that
people cite Einstein met both of those
people actually in 1930 and had a very
interesting exchange with Chaplin on the
meaning of Fame where both of them
basically didn't tell the truth
Einstein's prominence and his
extraordinary defense of reason of
course made him a target as well he
faced his first anti relativity crusade
being blamed for Jewish Physics in 1921
there was an official German anti
relativity society people tried to say
that this was an evil attack on common
sense that wasn't real science that this
was a malicious attempt to destroy
reason most of science in 1921 or 22
regarded this as ridiculous and Einstein
didn't have much to fear from it at that
point though it's notable that the
leading light of that society did become
the head of German physics when Hitler
took power Philipp Lonard of the Nobel
laureate whose work an experimentalist
whose work on the photoelectric effect
led to in Stein's breakthrough on the
quantum theory of light and Einstein's
Nobel Prize but these ironies abound in
Einstein's life but the threat was more
real than just you know an academic
battle he was good friends with Walter
Rathenau who was the most prominent
political Jew in Germany Graf now was
assassinated in 1922 the culmination
of a campaign of murder that decapitated
left 300 murders in three years all
aimed leaders of the left side of German
politics and Einstein was said to be
next on the list he left town he avoided
most of the hyperinflationary disaster
that followed came back when Germany
appeared to settle down and was present
in and used as a symbol throughout the
why Mar by Mar explosion of the Arts the
greatest monument in many ways of vimar
expressionist architecture is the
Einstein tower in Potsdam which was
designed to be a laboratory to test
general relativity be built by
Mendelssohn and I think opened in 1920
Einstein himself a sort of ambivalent
about the architecture but it's a
glorious building it's still there
rather disheveled if you go to Berlin
you can take the train to Potsdam and go
see it and you know people cited
Einstein directly or the implications of
his science it popped up in the visual
arts you saw it and literature people
claimed all kinds of things for new
music that were somehow tied to the
revolution in science that was somehow
tied to Einstein he was present to read
that Einstein overlapped with Berlin
with that kind of licentiousness and
interesting ways his friends were
friends who crossed over most notably a
ubiquitous count Harry Kessler was the
chronicler of all this great stuff he
intersected with all this stuff and he
actually tried to take part in the
political life of Weimar doing business
for the government trying to forge you
know international relations all that
sort of stuff and for five years it
appeared to work from 1924 at the end of
the hyperinflation era period up to 1929
with the great stock market crash and
begin the depression Farmar Berlin
though it still had people in it like
Joseph Goebbels who arrived in 1927
right-wing people who were infuriated by
Einsteins presence and the presence of
people like albums Berg whose music was
said to be a fountain poison or a
Corrupter of children this music you
shouldn't listen to this stuff and so on
and so forth
even though these divisions actually
existed some cases tragic comically
there were even two separate nudist
movements
one that was the socialist nudes on the
other which was the nationalist
right-wing nudes who of course could not
in their love of nature meet somehow in
the middle because that was you know
they were divided by their raw and naked
politics but all of this was mostly
under control until 1929 then came the
crash
then came the rise of the right which
was measurable in politics in the first
election of 1930 the first election
after the crash when Nazi vote totals
went from six hundred and forty thousand
nationwide trivial to six point four
million the second-highest total in the
country and the tragedy unrolled from
there but even here Einstein is
available to you if you want to
understand what's going on you can see
that in one incident this is the last
thing I'll tell you about it's a very
brief rapid jaunt through a much much
more complicated time and lots of great
stuff but I want to leave some time for
questions and I got to stop the last but
this last incident was I'm sure everyone
here has heard of the great novel All
Quiet on the Western Front which was
published - generally good notices and
not much you know not much political
controversy in Germany in the mid 1920s
and that novel is a novel of the
experience for ordinary German enlisted
men soldiers who are on the Western
Front
and it tells their you know their good
days and their bad days and by the end
of the war all four of them are by the
end of the novel and very close to end
of the war all four of them are dead and
you know the book was written explicitly
not to be political that's what the
author said remark but to try and
capture what it felt like to be a
soldier on the Western Front so he came
out the right wing did not like it there
was some opposition to it Freeman Dyson
in a very nice review of this book that
he just published noted that that in his
own family a relative who had been
raised in Germany in that period was
told that respectable people didn't read
that book because it was somehow
traitorous but the real trouble started
when Hollywood made its movie
in the western front which was shown all
around the world critical acclaim again
not a very political movie just a real
bad time in the war how you understand
that how you try and come to grips with
it it showed for one night in Berlin
Goebbels led a clock against it somebody
threw us somebody released rats there
were people throwing things at the
screen there are some fistfights they
managed to call the police get rid of
the Nazi thugs throw them out finished
the screening of the movie that night I
believe though there are different
accounts some say it was finished some
say it wasn't but the movie never
reopened in Berlin and finally the
Reichstag and the government acquiesced
in the Nazi demand that the movie be
censored and pulled from distribution in
Germany Einstein who was then on a
one-semester guest teaching assignment
at Caltech in Pasadena heard of this
made a point of requesting a special
screening at the studio that had
produced the the movie came out and said
it's a wonderful movie there's nothing
political about it it's just an attempt
to chronicle this experience and the
notion that the German government would
ban it is a defeat for democracy it
shouldn't happen
Einstein and Goebbels were in direct
head-to-head conflict at that point
Einstein and Hitler knew of each other
there was Einstein said he never had the
honor of meeting that fella and Einstein
tried to oppose them with all the power
of public notice of celebrity and a
rhetoric he could have he was trying to
be the voice of reason in an unreasoning
time and a place and we know the end of
the story in 1932 it became clear that
the rise to power of the far-right
was unstoppable wasn't absolutely clear
that it would be Hitler that was very
likely - I took a look around and
realized that not only was it not
possible to have the kind of untrammeled
thought that had been the whole reason
for him being in Berlin in the first
place
it wasn't even physically safe anymore
so he left he decided that was enough
the city that had once sought him out to
add luster to the crown to to its crown
that it claimed as the pinnacle of
Western civilization had become unfit
for that's what Einstein would have seen
it reasoned human habitation so he left
and we see the next steps being taken
into the abyss that was the middle of
the twentieth century I thought that was
a subject we're spending some time
trying to understand and I hope I've
intrigued you enough to pursue it and
the much greater length that I do in my
book thank you very much any questions
but when you you spoke before about the
biography of the great man how do you
manage to keep your feet under you when
you're as a writer when you're writing
about someone that has risen to
greatness it's interesting I mean one of
the things about being a biographer and
my cousin's actually also biographer and
he's working on Stalin right now talk
about somebody it's hard to keep your
your-your-your perspective on you
develop a relationship that is really it
is really a relationship even if the
conversations are somewhat one-sided and
it's very intimate I mean you really if
you spend long enough on it you really
have a sense that you've lived with this
person I mean I spent more waking hours
with Albert Einstein on my brain and
staring at his words trying to
understand where he lived and how he
lived and what he did and all that spent
more time than I did with my wife during
those years
and like all extended relationships
there are good times and bad times you
do discover certainly that the great men
or women that you Chronicle however
great they are
by any measure are human beings and they
have their flaws Einstein had enormous
flaws I didn't talk at all about
Einstein's love life his marriages his
sex life but his family life but he was
a lousy husband and father and there was
one letter I came across that was
released relatively late in the period
working on Einstein that was from his
stepdaughter to his stepdaughters former
lover and her mother's poses close
friend asking what she should do about
the notion that Einstein didn't care
whether he married her mother who had
been his mistress and and the woman who
taking care of him during his illness or
the much younger more nubile more
attractive daughter said you know
Einstein doesn't care which one of us
mother or daughter me or my mom that I
marry he leaves it up to us
this letter and it suggested that
Einstein had sort of had groped during a
kind of ugly way and all this sort of
stuff and and left her flummox because
it was clear from the letter she really
didn't want to marry him he didn't want
to have sex with him but didn't know
quite how to confront this whole thing I
read that letter and I was going you
know Albert you slug you know and you
know that's who he was he was not in
fact as far as you know the sort of
moral behavior to to the women in his
life in ptarth he wasn't you know an
unheard of libertine or aura you know he
wasn't a marquis de sade wasn't even as
as you know prolific as his physicist
colleagues Schrodinger who was you know
famous for his love life but but you
know he was not you know there were
there were unpleasant things about him
he could be very harsh to his friends
you know he could be a rude man he was
better he himself said with people in
the mass than with individuals so you
know that and after a while you know in
something you know there days we can
sort of go I don't really like this
person very much over time as in any
long and intimate relationship you find
you're either you develop just a hate
hate relationship and you get these
nasty bye you know dreadful marriages
that are that are you know you know
agreements to fight for 50 years or you
get these nasty biographies where the
biographer clearly lost it into said I'm
going to tell you everything horrible
about this person you thought was right
or you find some you go back to the
reason you found the person fascinating
and intriguing and attractive in the
first place and you you know but in that
case the bad stuff becomes a corrective
you know you just sort of remember he's
not Albert Einstein though he was called
the Jewish Saint and once joked when his
when his image went up on the wall of an
Episcopal Church in the West Side
New York they never thought it'd be a
Christian Saint too but he wasn't a
saint you know he was a guy and he was a
guy who had fabulous things to recommend
him personal courage moral courage
fabulous science and could treat the
people in his life like crap did you go
to speculate what might have happened
had Einstein left Berlin and come to for
example the US Princeton or Berkeley in
1914 or 18 with the different poles
Germany has a habit of lionizing its
scientists we don't or at least we
didn't in those time period we didn't
though it is notable that when Einstein
first came to New York in 1921 he got a
ticker-tape parade and he was besieged
by the press has to me everything what
do you think of prohibition I don't know
I own drink he said what do you mean
asked him you know what you think about
the death penalty was against it what
you think about abortion he's a foreign
woman yet you know he was asked you know
not what do you think about curved
space-time which he could have given you
a reason to answer on but all that other
stuff so you know he might have the the
the impact of the celebrity side of
Einstein story we're so used to you know
the mass media and the photographer's
lurking outside the house and all that
kind of stuff that it's hard to imagine
what it was like when that was first
happening and that was really the first
time it happened immediately after first
world war this you know the hunger for
this kind of entertainment was enormous
after the bloodletting and the
technology was there to give it an
Einstein was fodder for it so I think he
might have been lionized here just as
much as in Berlin if he'd come to United
States in 1914 that's a very to me
that's a very implausible counterfactual
he had no reason to go to the States
then before the horror of the war but
had he done so I think he would have had
much greater difficulty in achieving
general relativity I suspect he would
have done it because he already knew
that that was the defining problem and
he was just becoming aware at that
period that what he thought was his
solution to it was not correct as I
would certainly kept on going with it
and he would likely have been able to
figure it out but there's no question
that he benefited for example just
giving a series of talks to david
hilbert and hilbert group in gooding in
hilbert was the greatest mathematician
in europe of the day maybe the greatest
mathematician in the world who knows and
the talk stimulated Hilbert to start
studying general relativity he came up
with a formulation similar they're not
exactly like Einsteins at about the same
time in 1915 but it also catalyzed
Einsteins thinking to realize that what
he had done in 1912 thirteen really
really really wasn't adequate and he had
to find new mathematical apparatus and
some new conception that would allow him
to finish off what was to him clearly
already the right idea so he would have
lost that particular stimulus if he'd
come to the United States in 1914 and
that might have cost him some time I
don't think would have cost him general
relativity but it might have cost him
time yes well given that his research
led to a paradigm shift in science from
the atonium world picture to the
so-called relativity world picture seems
to be another undermining of sort of the
traditional basis of our understanding
of our society of Cosmos along with what
took place in the political and social
realms after the first world war seems
like he was part of the process of sort
of challenging undermining the whole
traditional understanding of the cosmos
and humankind that's and therefore maybe
I don't know why there were other people
like the Dada stand a surrealist doing
the same thing rationality was under
attack Freudian psychology
psychoanalytic theory so how does he fit
into that whole picture but it's a very
good observation and quite I'm not sure
I can answer the question certainly not
in a couple minutes but I'll give it a
try again an interesting sidelight
Einstein and Freud knew each other and
collaborated in 3233 on a little book
called why war when they exchanged
letters to try and figure out why the
world seemed to be set on so soon after
the disaster of World War one diving
back into the abyss and they didn't come
up with a satisfactory answer though
they both apparently enjoyed the
collaboration Einstein was extremely
skeptical of Freud he refused though
asked to nominate Freud for a Nobel
Prize and very pointedly said that Freud
would never have the opportunity of
psychoanalyzing
him interesting a few ayats I met young
before he met Freud because young and
Einstein overlapped in Zurich before the
war and Einstein it's known actually
went to a couple of Jung's sort of cell
but he was I think at least as sceptical
of young as he was afraid it is true
that Einsteins contributions to physics
took physics further and further away
from the common sense of view of the
natural world it had already been going
that direction Maxwell's theory you know
the electromagnetic theory was you know
already pushing the the edge of things
and you're beginning to get technology
that was clearly farm you know the whole
electro electrical electro dynamic
transformation of Europe that happened
in a generation incredibly quickly
started pushing technology again sort of
further out of sight and out of reach it
didn't just happen in the last ten years
of PCs in many ways the last decade or
two of the 19th century were as
disruptive and transforming as the last
decade or two of our century
but Einstein certainly pushed that
further and he appeared to assault
reason though the logical structure of
his theories was always rigorous it was
reasoned could only be understood
through the exercise of a rigorous
methyl apparatus did people like the
Dadaists and the other movements that
were available feed off the sense of
truth not perceivable directly by the
common senses of human guide absolutely
Einstein was and his science and the
other emerging Sciences you know wasn't
all Einstein in the early 20th century
even though I like to think it was but
certainly the the cultural movements fed
on that just as artists today will pick
up metaphors well or badly off the
internet off you know the revolution of
the biological sciences off physics you
know you see good art and bad art that
tries to play off those themes and
suggestions that the artists may or may
not have a clue what they are
referencing when they do so that was
certainly a case in the 20s and I think
that was one of the reasons why Einstein
described the Einstein Tower as quote
organic
not sure he really you know it has lots
of these lovely curved shapes and it's
quite swoopy I think this was supposed
to be a knee location of curved space
but I'm not sure if Einstein thought it
was but it is true that people could and
did use Einstein as sort of license to
say that conventional morality
conventional structures the world as we
know it is not the world that is
Einstein himself didn't say that but his
work was there for people to appropriate
and so in that sense yes he may have
been part of the problem
he himself I think was much more
constrained in the way he viewed what
his work actually said I mean it's a
topic that could go on for hour after
hour but that's that's a first
approximation first is what at 15 he
decides he wants to leave Germany I
wonder if you could talk a little bit
about what happened in those first 15
years that made him at such a young age
decide that and the second question is
during his time in Berlin was he
involved in organized leftist politics
or was he just a fellow traveler of some
kind the answer the second question is
yes it's a bit of both the answer the
first question the most important thing
in his first 15 years was the partly he
was affected by the failures of his
father's business and he just you know
hated the thought of being trained to
work a real job and you know certainly
he didn't sort of view just kind of
sticking the course in Germany as a
necessity because he didn't want to do
what his father had done and suffer the
problems in business that his father had
had under when he was very clear in in a
document written near the end of his
life that he was he was in fact aware of
what was going on the family he didn't
like it um though it is notable and
little-known that he took at his
father's request at two or three
business courses when he was at
university to go along with all his
physics courses which makes me wonder
you know what would have happened if
Albert had actually gone to Wall Street
and
you know III don't know it's dice or
deli in that area but thing that really
drove him out of Germany was his
experience of state education really all
the way along but particularly when he
got to the high school where he found
the methods of instruction loathesome he
fought with his teachers his teachers
fought with him he did note that there
was one extremely important incident
earlier than high school again the same
document written this kind of
autobiography he wrote it short at the
end of his life
when he said it you know he was required
by the state to have religious
instruction state did not require him to
have Christian religious instruction he
could be dead Jewish instruction which
he did but he had to have it and for a
year or so he was moved and convinced by
this and composed religious songs as he
sang on his way to school made his
parents stop eating pork all this sort
of stuff his parents were completely
secular Jews then he read a series of
popular science books and he realized
that what he had been told his lies
couldn't be true the stuff in the Bible
just couldn't work his work and he said
my god the state lied to me I'm being
coerced they're trying to turn me into
something I'm not and I mean it's easy
for an old man to look back on his
childhood and see the seeds of what he
became there but you know the the
empirical events I mean the there is
there is confirmation that those events
took place and he had his moment of
great religious fervor and then there's
real sloughing off of it
so I think there's the ring of truth to
that I think he did not like the sense
that Germany was this incredibly
coercive place and he saw that coercion
more or less wherever he looked as to
whether or not he was a fellow traveler
or an actual participant in left
politics he was a member of several
official bodies especially League of
nation bodies for international
scientific cooperation
he was so as a member of the vimar he
was a representative of hawai our German
government and of the left side of that
when there was a left he did sort of
personal jobs at personal requests of
people like right now who was the vimar
early if I'm our foreign minister so he
did official or semi official things but
he was sort of a born fellow traveller
than a joiner I mean he did also
starting in the early 20s he really did
profoundly important work
Zionism and the specific Zionist
movement headed by Theodor Herzl but he
never joined the Zionist movement and
the head of Germany Zionists warned
Herzl not to push him too hard because
as you know he's no Zionist that was
that was true there's one other thing I
wanted to mention in my talk and
forgotten it's sort of relevant to what
you were saying is the interesting about
Einstein through this period is the ups
and downs of his pacifism not really a
pacifist during the war though
increasingly revolts by things like his
friend harbors chemical warfare
experiments and the cost of the war
after the war he becomes a complete
pacifist and finally by the late twenty
C saying I would rather die than be
forced to take up arms it's horrible
people should resist the Selective
Service and so forth and so on which is
a change as I said from you know what he
was willing to do as a very young man
where he would have joined the Swiss
Army I believe but then after 33 he
changes he doesn't stay a committed
moral pacifist for whom doing violence
is so heinous that no circumstance will
make them consider it no he's not
Bertrand Russell here well it's not part
with that book there that Bertrand
Russell
instead he earlier than almost anyone
else said Hitler is somebody who will
not be persuaded by moral suasion you
know you're not gonna get him to behave
properly by being good people he's bent
on war he'll do enormous damage you have
to crush him concussion physically with
violence if the threat of violence does
not suffice Einstein understood that and
he wrote again in 33 very aligned who
was writing to fellow pacifist to a
growing use to sort of turning down sign
saying no you cannot behave that way
anymore
Einstein you know one of the things
about Albert Einstein you were asking me
how you sort of deal with him over over
the years one thing I really did come to
grips with his Einstein was really smart
you know he wasn't just a great
physicist he was a very smart man he had
a very clear-headed view of the world
and most importantly he had the capacity
to change his mind apparently without
great cost on most things not on the
quantum theory but on very very many
things
the fact that he became a pop idol and
evidently even international pop idol
and yet he's working in a realm that's
beyond the understanding you say
challenges common sense and he's working
in a Rome that's beyond the
understanding of all but twelve people
maybe I'm exaggerating but how how did
that come to be because people really
couldn't it's not like the the the
popular the populist could appreciate
what he was saying I think you've hit on
exactly why he did become such a iconic
figure
he said it and his as a friend and
biographer PI used to confirm this in
conversation with me he said you know
what really made it work the reason he
became such a a pop figure is that
people didn't understand him and there
was this pleasure of the mystery they
could hear these glorious things that
was romantic and I said space is curved
light bends time flows at different
rates depending on where you are or what
you're doing there's a fourth dimension
out there you know things change as they
champion all kind of space and time
change as you go faster and faster I
mean these are marvelous things and your
head can bend around them and it sounds
cool and you say alright why are you
late for school I was wandering in the
fourth dimension er yeah space curve
differently today I mean it's this
romantic kind of pleasure that you don't
really have to come to grips with and
you can admire this person not simply
for finding these things out but for
having done the work for you you don't
have to understand it cuz he can and you
can just admire him for it and pi said
you know it was really remarkable after
the war there was a this was you know
this Jewish sage comes along and says
there is this extraordinary reality and
here it is don't worry there are truths
in the world it's not all uprooted and
you know it's okay
and you know it was almost that sense of
this kind of authority even though I had
sinned hated being Authority in essence
telling you there's this great mystery
out there but it's alright I've tamed it
that made him in some ways even more of
an icon and he would have been if he you
know invented the transistor
I'm curious as a writer did you choose
to focus on instan be because of his
historic significance or do you have a
background in science was that your
interest in him that got you started a
bit of both I did a bit of science and
history of science in my in my
undergraduate academics but I then
became a science journalist a science
writer and then a science broadcaster
television producer for a long time
before I really dared confront Einstein
and in fact that it was my television
career that made me come up against
science and cos in 1988 or so I realized
that the 75th anniversary of the
invention for general relativity was
coming up this really I mean that idea
is one of the great landline it really
did changed the way we understand
physical reality and I in a fundamental
way
and I was a science editor of the Nova
series on PBS at the time I suppose to
be there you know science arbitrators
either the voice of authority with all
the TV types and I realized if somebody
came out to an Austrian says so what was
this relativity stuff I could wave my
hands and if they didn't know anything I
could probably fake it but I didn't
really have a good answer for them so I
started reading I started reading more
than that started reading more and then
I got hooked so you know are you a
writer you know as you know from family
experience if not personal things hit
writers funny and sometimes they nag at
you for a decade before they turn into
an actual project or requirement that
you have to say it and I've been
wondering about Isaac Newton for a long
time man I'm just tiptoeing up to the
edge of wanted to write something wrong
about him
so was he Einstein served as a conduit
for reintroduction of mystery or some
sense of Rhian Chapman in the world
through his obtuse thinking and thoughts
that people couldn't understand on the
common sensical level and there were
what religion had failed to offer at
that time maybe science through Einstein
was offering I think that's true and I
think there's a certain amount in which
that's still true and there is there is
a real tension and and you see a lot of
bad books right now about you know
science and religion coalescing is a
sudden the other thing but I think the
fact is that
that science has in different ways
absorbed what used to be the territory
of religion which said it's interesting
cuz you know until this juxtaposition
came up I hadn't really thought of this
expressing Newton remember took an awful
lot of the romance out of the world
right
Laplace the great french astronomer and
physicist told napoleon that you know if
you if I know the starting position of
every object in the universe I could
predict the future without without limit
he was wrong for other reason for
reasons he did not know but you know
this this was the you know outcome of
the triumph of Newtonian determinism
Napoleon is said to have said to him
that where'd he where do you fit God
into your scheme and Laplace is said to
over apply this is all apocryphal that I
have no need of that hypothesis we're up
on one of his scientist friends at ha
but it's such a lovely hypothesis it
explains so many things but Einstein
comes back and introduces all these
weird concepts and you get the sense
that an Einstein himself was not a
religious man in the sense of having any
credence in revealed religion but he
referred to himself as a religious man
in the sense that he was aware of and
awed by the mysterious fact that the
universe displays an order that is
intelligible to human being and that is
truly I think the religious experience
that is accessible to people who are
committed to the scientific worldview
and Einstein was certainly a great
poster boy for that view paces book
includes a lot of the mathematical
physics in it does yours know if you
want that go to place my book is ace is
a it is I attempt to cover in a way
that's intelligible to you know any
interested layperson what Einstein
scientific accomplishments were and what
the scientific context of his work and I
don't just you know obviously I go back
to explain general relativity draws from
the work he did before he got to Berlin
and special ativy so I hope I give a
good context for that and a good account
that is non mathematical but the other
aspect of the work is to try and
understand that man and that works place
in the social history and the cultural
history of its of its time so which
piece did a little bit of but but that
the focus of his book you know and if
you want a pure Einstein biography that
takes them from birth to death there are
some very good ones out there I used is
one of my helps in this book Albrecht
foldings I think that was the best of
the ones that were available to me but
there plenty of pure biographies mine is
combination of biography cultural
history you know metropolitan biography
I'm not sure what you call trying to do
the life's life story of a city but it's
it did it it's the story of a person a
place and a time everybody had I'm
wondering about who you interviewed
either his family or his colleagues or
or Berliner
I interviewed more of those for the film
I did the two-hour Nova biography on
Albert Einstein but the know most of the
people who worked with Albert Einstein
are dead John Wheeler is still alive and
I spoke to him in the context of doing
the film a brown Pais was alive during
the film and when I was starting in the
book I spoke with him there are a fair
number of people who knew I'm stunned in
his American days there very very few
people who who knew him in his Berlin
days Gabriela Oppenheimer ara
lived 202 in action knew him before he
went to Berlin as well as in Provence we
first met him in 1911 I spoke to her
just before she died and for Berlin
itself there a number of good histories
of Berlin but what I really used was the
wonderful German archives of newspapers
and pamphlets and all that sort of which
they were the Germans do make good
archives and I took full advantage of
them I'm very grateful to the German
government for keeping them and allowing
such greater use of them thank you all
so much
Thomas Levinson is author of Einstein in
Berlin it's published by Bantam Books on
the web at Bantam Dell com next week on
public lives a biography of American
philosopher and education reformer John
Dewey you can find out more about the
authors and books